Here's a new packet layout when IPSec
operates in transport mode and uses ESP.
An IPSec header,
in this case the ESP header,
is inserted after
the original IP header.
The ESP header includes
the security parameter index and
a sequence number, and
we will discuss these shortly.
The ESP header also includes the IV for
encryption.
The ESP trailer has
the padding information, and
pointer to next header,
such as the TCP or UDP header.
The packet payload and
the ESP trailer are both encrypted.
But the ESP header is not,
because it provides information,
in particular, the security perimeter
index that tells the receiving end
how to decrypt the payload.
For example, which algorithm and
shared secret key to use.
The ESP header, and
the encrypted payload, are then
hashed together with a secret key.
And the hash value is stored as
the message authentication code for
the receiver to verify the authenticity
and integrity of the message.